die Bundestagswahl ist nun zwei Tage her
vor gut 50 Stunden haben die Wahllokale
geschlossen und dass wir danach gesehen
haben vor allem bei der Union das war
ein ganz merkwürdiges Theaterstück das
hat mich eigentlich erinnert an Gerhard
Schröder 2005 auch Erinnerung an Donald
Trump 2020 wurden wach und
Kanzlerkandidat Armin Laschet war doch
wirklich der Meinung er habe eine
Regierungsauftrag bekommen obwohl seine
Union das schlechteste Wahlergebnis
aller Zeiten eingefahren hat obwohl die
Union ein Viertel ihrer Stimmen zum
ohnehin schon schlechten Ergebnis von
2017 eingebüßt hat ergo Armin Laschet
will weiter Kanzler werden aber die
vergangenen 50 Stunden haben gezeigt
dass selbst der Bratwurst packt mit
Markus Söder der Freitag vor gut einer
Woche also vor zehn Tagen geschlossen
wurde mittlerweile überhaupt nichts mehr
wert ist Armin Laschet steht allein im
Wind es gab heute Rücktrittsforderungen
deswegen
das ist glaube ich das deutlich jetzt
auch einmal zu sagen Armin Laschet die
Zeit ist vorbei Wolfgang Schäuble würde
sagen ich over und es wird Zeit für
Armin Laschet zu erkennen was der
Bürgerwelle ist aber auch was ein großer
Teil in seiner eigenen CDU mittlerweile
denkt er hat das Vertrauen verspielt er
hat das Gespür für Bürger aber auch für
viele in der eigenen Partei komplett
verloren und deswegen ist es Zeit den
Weg frei zu machen für einen echten
Neuanfang
[Musik]
ja ich habe den Betrieb ich lausche dem
fasziniert und frage mich aber für was
für Neuanfang weil die Menschen die dann
sozusagen
dran wären in die Ämter der Macht in die
mächtigsten Ende gekommen sind ja nicht
etwa eine Frischzellenkur sondern die
üblichen Verdächtigen Anführungszeichen
ich glaube dass Armin Laschet sich so
schwer damit tut den Weg frei zu machen
weil er auch spürt dass es gar keinen
aufbruchssignal dann gibt sondern die
pästchen waren halt einfach anders
verteilt und jetzt kommt es
entscheidende für ihn ist dann alles wie
du gesagt hast over weil
es mir schwer tun mir vorzustellen dass
der große Verlierer Armin Laschet dann
eine große politische Zukunft in
Nordrhein-Westfalen hat aber da schaue
ich schon den Wald in der Runde an hat
sich festgelegt genau das hat sich
festgelegt seinen Weg geht nach Berlin
ob ins Kanzleramt oder auf einen
Abgeordneten Stuhl ist ja im Moment noch
völlig offen Kanzleramt oder hinter Bank
das ist das was wir jetzt vor der Wahl
steht er eigentlich jetzt ja es gibt da
noch andere Möglichkeiten
Fraktionsvorstand Stellvertreter oder
wie ich da Ausschuss Vorsitzender aber
sie haben schon recht kein Vergleich mit
dem Amt im Ministerpräsident in
Nordrhein-Westfalen ich weiß aber aus
der Heimat dass man dort schon überlegt
wer könnte denn jetzt Spitzenkandidat
werden der Landtagswahl ist ja im
Frühjahr 22 das kommt jetzt schnell und
dann also mein Favorit wäre Hendrik wüst
aber dann wird es auch einen
Generationenwechsel geben der ist ja nun
deutlich über dort gibt es den dann oh
ja
ich glaube auch die die die Sehnsucht
nach einer Rückkehr würde sich in
Grenzen halten weil dann das Gefühl
aufgeben die Träume in Berlin sind nicht
wahr geworden dann doch wieder zurück in
die Staatskanzlei nach Düsseldorf ich
glaube was man feststellen kann auch
nach diesem Ergebnis für die Union und
nach den vorangegangenen Monaten sie
sind zwar aus dem Landesverband von
Armin Laschet haben ja auch unterstützt
aber müssen doch wahrscheinlich auch
feststellen wir brauchen eigentlich in
der deutschen Politik mehr Amerika also
dieses Thema Vorwahlen dass sich mehrere
Kandidaten auch in der CDU
beispielsweise oder in der Union in der
SPD vorstellen und sagen ich möchte
laufen und das aber auch ganz normale
Bürger keine Partei Soldaten sondern
ganz normale Bürger die Chance haben zu
sagen also wenn der Wolfgang Bosbach
antreten würde für das Bundeskanzleramt
bei der cdu/csu dann würde ich ihn
unterstützen deswegen würde ich bei
Ihnen sagen machen sie das
sie lachen
Argument nein aber nein
aber warum bestimmt denn nur ein Mini
Zirkel eigentlich wer überhaupt zur Wahl
ja Pause ist natürlich kompliziert da
war es ja zweite Parteien sind ich kann
Ihnen sagen ist ja doch ist eine sehr
selbstbewusste Partei aber wir haben das
alles schon mal gehabt wir haben die
Roadshow der SPD Parteivorsitzenden
gehabt und wer ist es geworden Olaf
Scholz den man nicht als
Parteivorsitzender haben Punkt ist ein
anderer mein Punkt ist ist das die
SPD-Mitglieder über ihren SPD-Kandidaten
abstimmen sondern der Punkt ist dass die
Bundesbürger abstimmen können wen würden
Sie denn eigentlich bei der SPD gut
finden wen so ist es Amerika ja auch da
können sie als Republikaner auch bei den
imperialen wollen so und das ist doch
der Punkt und dann können ganz normale
Bürger sagen Wolfgang Bosbach super aber
hätten sie plötzlich wieder Chance ist
jetzt aber deswegen ein schräges
Beispiel weil wir ein anderes Problem
hatten nicht das es ging doch in der
Union im Kern um verhindern zuerst mal
sollten Friedrich Merz verhindert werden
dann wurde es Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer
dann sollte Friedrich Merz wieder
verhindert werden dann kam noch Norbert
Röttgen dazu am Ende wurde es Armin
Laschet und ganz zum Schluss sollte
Markus Söder verhindert werden und
wieder wurde es der Armin Laschet das
hat fast seine Pointe und an als Gipfel
verhindert die Partei damit das im
Kanzler stellen
zwar der Favorit der Basis und nach
allen Umfragen wussten wir Markus Söder
ist der Favorit auch das Publikum der
Bevölkerung aber der CDU-Bundesvorstand
hat sich anders entschieden und eins
kann ich Ihnen sagen als sie ihren
Irrtum erkannten verdoppelten sie ihre
Anstrengung da wird keiner sagen das war
eine falsche Entscheidung wir hätten mit
anderen besser abgeschnitten die werden
alle sagen das war richtig aber
Wolfgang Schäuble wir haben hier die
spannende these gehört ich glaube letzte
Woche hat einer unserer Gäste gesagt
Angela Merkel wollte Markus Söder und
deswegen wurde es Armin Laschet weil Sie
Armin Laschet nicht wollte und der
Bundesvorstand sich dann durchgesetzt
hat ein bisschen schlecht jedenfalls
Volker Bouffier und Wolfgang Schäuble
haben gesagt an der Partei dass da
unlogisch also Wolfgang Schäuble und
Volker Bouffier haben ein solches
Gewicht im Bundes natürlich nur eine
Stimme aber ein solches Gewicht vor
allen Dingen Wolfgang Schäuble und er
hat zum Schluss den Ausschlag dafür
gegeben dass es Armin Laschet wurde auch
mit dem Argument die große stolze CDU
kann sich doch nicht
dummes zieren lassen von der von der
kleinen Schwesterpartei die CSU noch die
größere CD das ist ja wirklich im
politischen kleinen klein gedacht einmal
sagen
also ich weiß auch wirklich nicht ob er
dem armen Laschet auch nicht zu viel von
misserfakt der CDU hier anders also er
war jetzt sicherlich keinen strahlender
nee alles gewesen ja aber ich glaube die
Probleme der Partei gehen schon tiefer
als nur die Nominierung von Armin
Laschet Punkt 1 und Punkt 2 weil es weil
ihm jetzt auch jeder kleinste Fehltritt
und manchmal Dinge wo ich denke das war
vielleicht noch nicht mal ein solcher so
im Übermaß angelastet wird also
beispielsweise seine Äußerungen kurz
nach der Wahl das auch eher anstreben
würde eine Regierung zu bilden da würde
ich sagen ja wieso denn nicht also wieso
sollte es denn nicht zumindest versuchen
ja also dieser ganze Terminus
Regierungsauftrag das ist ja letztlich
eine eine Erfindung es gibt keinen
Regierungsauftrag es gibt einfach ein
Wahlergebnis mit dem kann man Mehrheiten
bilden das kann die Union mit FDP und
Grünen zusammen genauso wie die SPD ist
kann und hat das jetzt weiterhin
versucht ist absolut nachvollziehbar und
ich weiß halt also sozusagen ich finde
es breitet es sich da so ein bisschen so
ein Defätismus in der Union aus der
eigentlich vielleicht
verfrüht ist oder ihr schadet aber bzw
der hat sich schon vor der Wahl
ausgebreitet das war für mich das
erschreckende also das sozusagen dieses
dieses gemeinsame Ziel Armin Laschet
Kanzler werden zu lassen gar nicht
wirklich fühlbar war sondern es ist
immer gesagt worden und dann kam es in
die Kameras aus waren zum Augenrollen ja
wir wissen schon der Armin Laschet und
das fand ich schon komisch ich will aber
noch mal was anderes machen wir sind
jetzt auch in so einer Polit Berlin
Raumschiff Diskussion ich mache mir so
ein bisschen Sorgen wie das alles was
jetzt in Berlin stattfindet wieder auf
die Bürger wirkt nämlich ich bin nicht
sicher ob es auf die wirkt das ist jetzt
das Ringen um eine Bundesregierung oder
der Kampf verschiedener Einstellungen
wer vorne liegen soll sondern ich habe
das Gefühl es ist eher das Schauspiel
des bestätigt wie man sich Berlin oft zu
Unrecht aus der Distanz vorstellt es
geht eigentlich eigentlich nur um Posten
es geht nur um pfünde es geht nur um die
Bank im Sitzen im Bundestag zu
verteidigen und wenn man es verloren hat
zu stänkern es geht nur um Renten um
Abfindungen um Ansprüche das vermittelt
sich mit jedem Tag und die Person völlig
zu Unrecht an der sich das festmacht und
das kriegt er jetzt auch noch ab
sozusagen das Armin Laschet mit diesem
ich mache den Weg nicht frei irgendwie
sehnt sich glaube ich
das Land nach einer Befreiung nun macht
doch den Weg frei so wie Jan fordert und
dann sollen die sich endlich
zusammenraufen und es machen und wenn
dann einer sagt ich hoffe das bis
Weihnachten der Regierung gebildet ist
dass er gar nicht dabei
brinkhaus-alarm bekomme gerade aufs Ohr
gesagt dass Ralf Brinkhaus der
cdu/csu-fraktionsvorsitzende
wiedergewählt wurde für ein halbes Jahr
das ist wichtig für alle die bereits
Brinkhaus gar nicht kennen
möglicherweise Ralf Brinkhaus ist der
Chef der cdu/csu-fraktion es gab einen
großen Machtkampf darum darf er sich
heute turnusgemäß wieder wählen lassen
für ein Jahr das wollte Armin Laschet
nicht genau das wollte angelaschet
verhindern und jetzt hat man sich auf
ein Kompromiss geeinigt ein halbes Jahr
ist jetzt Ralf Brinkhaus oder für ein
halbes Jahr erstmal gewählt ganz frisch
mit etwas über 170 stimmen also es war
schon zu jung unionzeiten so jetzt kommt
Opfer erzählt
70er Jahre das war ein ganz wichtiger
Satz immer Sachfragen sind wichtiger als
Personalfragen die wichtigste Sachfrage
ist was wird aus mir so jetzt hat man
natürlich einen großen Unterschied ob
man in der Opposition ist dann hast du
einen wirklich wichtigen Posten zu
vergeben dass der Fraktionsvorsitzende
als erster dann antwortet als stärkster
Oppositionspartei auf die Regierung oder
ob der in der Regierung bist dann hast
du Minister dann hast du
Staatssekretärin hast du ein Bataillon
vom Beauftragten fällt alles weg
dagegen kann ich auch verstehen dass
Armin Laschet sagt wir sind wir sind
Findung sondierungsphase wir wissen noch
nicht wie es weitergeht wir wollen
dieses wichtige Amt jetzt nicht für ein
Jahr zementieren und ich wette ich wette
sollte es so kommen ich tippe ja immer
noch auf Jamaika aber sollte es so
kommen dass die Union in der Opposition
ist dann wird es noch andere bewerten
mit allem einem Respekt auch für die
Union die ja ganz ganz viele Verdienste
um dieses Land auch hat was ist das
jetzt für eine Lösung was ist das für
eine Lösung es ist wieder das ist das
ist lauwarmer Pudding den wir hier sehen
es ist nicht wir machen Neuanfang es ist
auch nicht Armin Lasche stellt sich hin
was eigentlich wollte ich werde
Fraktionschef um die Verhandlung für ein
Jamaika-Bündnis was er ja immer noch
anstrebt von vorne wie so schön heißt zu
führen nein man einigt sich auch nicht
auf Ralf Brinkhaus wie es die Sachen
gerade selbst die Statuten vorsehen für
ein Jahr gewählt und nein er wird für
ein halbes Jahr gewesen ist ein
klassischer ich möchte fast sagen Merkel
Kompromiss man laviert sich durch die
die verloren haben Klavieren sich wieder
durch und die die jetzt jung sind und
antreten wollen die kriegen noch keine
Chance also es ist für und Klaus hat
glaube ich gerade eben richtig
angesprochen für die Menschen die sich
Berlin nicht aus der Berliner
Perspektive anschauen sondern aus der
Brandenburger der bayerischen oder auch
Politik so wie sie glauben dass sie wäre
so ist sie auch ein Handwerksmeister der
der einen Auftrag verliert
Handwerksmeister der Auftrag verliert ja
der verliert den Auftrag und der kann
ich noch sagen jetzt komme ich mit dem
und mit dem und ich will da irgendwie
ran wenn jemand so dramatisch einbüßt da
hat er verloren das muss man akzeptieren
das ist guter
stilfinger geben
[Musik]